احييكم مشاهدينا واهلا بكم الى هذه الساعه
الاخباريه من العربيه والتي نخصص جلها
لتغطيه التطورات في السودان وطبعا سنتناول
كل الملفات الدوليه كالعاده نبدا
بالعناوين
طيران الجيش السوداني يستهدف مواقع قوات
الدعم السريه في محيط مطار الخرطوم
والاخيره ترد بالمضادات
اؤكد لكم انه عندما تنجلي هذه الازمه
قريبا
وتتحقق وتسيطر الشرعيه في البلاد مبعوث
البرهان يعلن جاهزيه الجيش للدخول بعمليه
سياسيه شامله ويتعهد بعدم اقصاء اي كيان
واستمرارا لعمليات الاجلاء عبر بورتسودان
سفينه سعوديه تصل ميناء جده وعلى متنها
رعايه اغلبهم امريكيون
في ساعتنا الاخباريه ايضا
الدفاع الروسيه تعلن اتخاذها خطوات لتسريع
انتاج الاسلحه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اعمله الدخان تتصاعد من مناطق في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم مشهد مالوفا
فرغم الهدن المعلنه لا تزال الاشتباكات
والقصف المتبادل بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع وفيما يدور حديث عن هدنه جديده
لاسبوع بموافقه مبدئيا من الطرفين اكد
الجيش ان الهدف من الهدن المعلنه انساني
ولا تفاوض مع قوات الدعم
[موسيقى]
رغم الاتفاق مشاهدينا على تمديد جديد
للهدنه السادسه المعارك تتواصل بين الجيش
السوداني والدعم السريع في اكثر من موقع
في السودان سابدا مع ولايه الخرطوم هناك
ثلاث مناطق متوتره تشهد عمليات الخرطوم
العاصمه
واندرمان وايضا خرطوم بحري في وسط الخرطوم
وتحديدا في محيط القصر الجمهوري كما نتابع
هنا حيث تقول قوات الدعم انها تسيطر عليه
دوله انفجارات وتصاعدت اعمده الدخان
واستمر تحليق طائرات الجيش سانتقل الان
الى المنطقه الاكثر توترا وهي محيط
القياده العامه للجيش والقوات المسلحه
السودانيه ودائما نتحدث عن الخرطوم حيث
تتواصل الانفجارات والاشتباكات العنيفه
بين طرفي الصراع هناك هناك ايضا منطقه
القياده العامه التي تعرف بالخط الامني
والتي تضم كما تشاهدون هنا
مبنى الاستخبارات مبنى القوات البحريه
السودانيه رئاسه اركان القوات الجويه
السودانيه والقياده العامه للقوات المسلحه
ورئاسه الاركان وكل هذه ما زالت كلها تحت
سيطره الجيش السوداني اما محيط القياده
العامه فما زال يخضع لسيطره الدعم السريع
والذي يشمل عددا من الشوارع سانتقل الان
الى الخرطوم بحري كما نتابع في هذه
الخريطه حيث تشهد اشتباكات متقطعه ويقوم
الجيش بتمشيط المنطقه من قوات الدعم
السريع
تحركنا من يوم الارض من الخرطوم فكان
المعساه يعني صعبه جدا
ويتحركنا عدد احنا 28
والاولاد يعني ما عندهم تاشيره وخليناهم
الان ومتحركين احنا طلعنا من تحت الاذانات
من تحت الدرب وطلاله من يعني طلعنا من
الاجوبه التوتر والضرب
لحد ما وصلنا
اعلنت وزاره خارجيه جنوب السودان ان
الرئيس مجلس السياده السوداني قائد الجيش
عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد قوات الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان دقلو وافق من حيث
المبدا على هدنه لمده سبعه ايام تبدا يوم
الخميس المقبل وقالت الوزاره في بيان ان
البرهان
هاتفي مع رئيس جنوب السودان على تسميه
ممثلين عنهما للمشاركه في محادثات سلام
تعقد في مكان من اختيارهما
الى ذلك قال السفير دفع الله الحاج مبعوثه
رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني ان الجيش
السوداني يتعاطى مع الهدنه على اساس انها
هدنه انسانيه نافيا ان يكون هناك اي تفاوض
مع قوات الدعم السريع مفهومنا الان فيما
يتعلق بالهدنه هي هدنه انسانيه
ليست هنالك ليس هنالك حديث عن
اي اتفاق ولا تفاوض مباشر مع المليشيا
المتمرده نعم اقول لك نحن
سندعو
الجامعه العربيه
والاتحاد الافريقي
للاطلاع بدور فيما يتعلق بهذه الهدنه
والدول التي بادرت بها وهي المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
الامريكيه
ونامل ان يكون للجامعه العربيه ثقلا ووزنا
وخاصه ان الاخ الامين العام للجامعه
العربيه قد عبر عن مشاعر
مؤيده للشرعيه في السودان منذ اليوم الاول
في هذا الاثناء وانا اتحدث معكم صدر قرار
من الجامعه العربيه
نص القرار على
التاكيد على الشرعيه في السودان وهي شرعيه
القوات المسلحه كمؤسسه وطنيه مسؤوله من
حمايه امن واستقرار السودان
القرار نص ايضا على وطالب باخلاء قوات
الدعم السريع للمستشفيات التي تحتلها وعدم
الارتكاز فيها وعدم
اتخاذ العاملين في المجال الطبي دروعا
بشريه
بخصوص العمليه السياسيه وعدم مبعوثه رئيس
مجلس السياده السوداني
في عمليه سياسيه شامله لا يقصى منها احد
واكد لكم انه عندما تنجلي هذه الازمه
قريبا
وتتحقق وتسيطر الشرعيه في البلاد
سيكون الامر
خلافه ما كان عليه بمعنى ان يتم
الدخول
وترتيب عمليه سياسيه واسعه شامله
لا يتم فيها اقصاء اي من الكائنات
السياسيه السودانيه الا ما سبق ان اتفق
عليه السودانيين للتمهيد
للانتقال الديمقراطي الحر
[موسيقى]
من جانبه قال عضو مجلس السويس السياده
السوداني الفريق اول ياسر العطا في
تصريحاته خاصه للعربيه ان الجيش يسيطر على
السودان مشيرا الى ان الدعم السريع يحتمي
بوجوده بالاحياء المدنيه المقتظه
بالمدنيين وله قناصه لحمايته متحدثا عن
خطط استراتيجيه للقضاء عليه خلال اسبوعين
على حد قوله
وصلت المعارك لسيطره كامله على كل ربوع
السوداني
عدد جيوب قليله في ولايتين اما العاصمه
القوميه والتي تم حجز معظم قوات الخونه
والاعمال المتمردين فيها فلازلت المعارك
جاريه وغواتنا المسلحه متوازنه ومتماسكه
تحضر انتصارات متتاليه على العدو المتمرد
تمثل التي يحتمي قوات التمرد فهو يحتمل
بمنازل المواطنين المواطنين المدنيين وبعض
المستشفيات وبعض المدارس خاصه في الاحياء
المختصه بالمدنيين ايضا احتماءهم وفي
مناطق فيها منشات حيويه
لا تتعرض للتدمير اي اي ايضا احيانا
يتحركون من مكان لاخر في بسرعه كبيره في
طرق الطرق
اماكن التي يقضي فيها المدنيين حاجياتهم
ومعايشهم وايضا تستخدم لاجلاء البعثات
الاجنبيه
وعلى الاسلحه المنازل في الاحياء المكتظه
بالسكان ايضا يوجد قناصه لحمايتهم عشان
كذا التعامل معهم يكون صعب لكن الان هيئه
قياده القوات المسلحه تضع الخطط الكفيله
بتدميرهم نهائيا
هذا واظهرت الصور استهداف طيران الجيش
السوداني لاهداف وتمركزات تابعه لقوات
الدعم السريع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بالمقابل قالت قوات الدعم السريع في بيان
لها انها اسقطت طائره من طراز ميك تابعه
للجيش السوداني في الخرطومة وذكرت قوه
الدعم السريع انها تصدت لغارات عده شنها
الجيش السوداني صباح اليوم على مناطق
سكنيه في الخرطوم
نشر حساب
المتخصص بالخرائط الحربيه خريطه لمنطقه
المعارك في الخرطوم حيث تظهر الخريطه
سيطره واضحه للجيش في اغلب مناطق العاصمه
خصوصا من جهه الشمال اما في وسط العاصمه
الخرطوم فتظهر الخريطه حاله تجاذب بين
الجيش والدعم السريع في وقت تتوسع سيطره
قوه الدعم باتجاه جنوب العاصمه
اتهم الجيش السوداني قوات الدعم السريع
بسرقه سيارات المواطنين والمغادره بها الى
خارج الخرطومه وطلب الجيش السوداني
المواطنين الانتباه لسياراتهم لانها اصبحت
محل استهداف من جهه اخرى نفت قوات الدعم
السريع هذه الاتهامات معتبره انها محاوله
للوقيع بينها وبين المواطنين لكن الجيش لن
يتمكن من ذلك على حد وصفها كما اتهم الدعم
السريه قوات الجيش بقصف عدد من المرافق
الخدميه بالطائرات
وفي اطار المطالبات السودانيه المدنيه
بالتفاوض دع ياسر عرمان الناطق الرسمي
باسم قوى الحريه والتغيير في السودان الى
مظاهرات واسعه في المناطق غير المتاثره
بالصراع للدفع نحو التفاوض ووقف الحرب
واكد عرمان ان القرى والمدن التي لا
تشملها الحرب عليها ان تخرج بشكل واسع
للدفع للتفاوض ووقف الحرف في البلاد مؤكدا
ان التفاوض سيقود البلاد الى القضايا التي
طرحت للمعالجه في الاتفاق الايطالي قائلا
انه لابد من قوات مسلحه مهنيه واحده وحكم
مدني في السودان
قبل ذلك اقترح رئيس الوزراء السوداني
السابق عبد الله حمدوك اجراء حوار عاجل
بين الجيش والدعم السريع لتوفير الاساس
لوقف دائم لاطلاق النار بالاضافه الى
الاتفاق على انشاء وممرات انسانيه دائمه
واقترح حمدوك ايضا اشراك المدنيين
السودانيين في مفاوضات شامله واستئناف
العمليه السياسيه مؤكدا على ان استمرار
الحرب في السودان وانتشارها في رقعه اوسع
قد يضر العالم باسره
تحركنا من يوم الارض من الخرطوم فكان
المعساه يعني صعبه جدا
ويتحركنا عدد
والاولاد يعني ما عنده عشيره وخليناهم
الان ومتحركين احنا طلعنا من تحت الادانات
من تحت الدرب وطلاله من يعني طلعنا من
الاجوبه التوتر والضرب لحد ما وصلنا
اعلنت الخارجيه السعوديه عدد من تم
اجلائهم من السودان حتى الان والذي بلغ
و629 شخصا من رعايه
واثنتين من هذه الجنسيه وقالت الخارجيه
السعوديه ان عدد المواطنين الذين تم
اجلائهم من السودان بلغت 239
اخرهما وصل مساء الثلاثاء على متن سفينه
جلاله الملك الرياض الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه في جده
قالت المتحدثه باسم مكتب المفوض السامي
للامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين اولغاس
الرادو ان اكثر من 100 الف لاجئ عبروا من
السودان الى الدول المجاوره هربا من
الصراع بينما نزح مئات الالاف بسبب العنف
داخل البلاد سوف تشير التفسيرات الى ان
اكثر من 100,000 لاجئ هم من بين اولئك
الذين فروا من السودان الى البلدان
المجاوره ويشمل هذا الرقم ايضا اللاجئين
في جنوب السودان المفوضيه الساميه للامم
المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين حددت الى جانب
الحكومات والشركاء رغم تخطيط اولي لاكثر
من 800,000 وعائد قد يفرون من السودان الى
البلدان المجاوره
المتحدث باسم المنظمه الدوليه للهجره قال
بدوره ان عدد النازحين ارتفع بوتيره سريعه
في الاسبوعين الماضيين بسبب القتال
المتواصل بين المكونين العسكريين
نزح ما لا يقل عن
334 الف شخص داخليا نتيجه الصراع الحاصل
وفقا لتقرير شبكه قياس تتبع النزوح
التابعه للمنظمه الدوليه للهجره ارتفع عدد
النازحين خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين نتيجه
تواصل الصراع في السودان جميع حالات
النزوح مرتبطه بالظروف الصعبه والازمات
التي زادت منذ عام 2022
[موسيقى]
القنصليه المصريه التي تصدر تاشيرات دخول
المواطنين من الرجال السودانيين من سن 16
عاما وحتى 50 عاما
فاستقبلت حتى الان اكثر من عشرين الف لاجئ
سوداني اغلبهم من اقليم دارفور وهو نفس
عدد اللاجئين تقريبا الذين فروا الى جنوب
السودان معظمهم من السودانيين الذين
يعيشون بالحزام الفاصل بين الجارتين
بالاضافه الى ثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه لاجئ
اتجهوا الى اثيوبيا عبر معبر الجلابات في
ولايه القضارف العدد الاقل كان الى
جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى
1500 لاجئ نظرا لكون الحدود بين البلدين
مغلقه
اعلنت ولايتان البحر الاحمر وسونار السونا
السودانيتان حاله الطوارئ لمده شهر بحسب
وكاله انباء السودان وكان والي البحر
الاحمر المكلف فتح الله الحاج اصدر امرا
بحظر نقل السلع الاستراتيجيه خارج حدود
الولايه الا بموافقه الجهات المختصه
دائما من مدينه بورسودان معنا زميلنا نزار
بداوي مراس العربيه نزار اهلا بك معنا
ماذا لدينا من تفاصيل حول حاله الطوارئ
التي اعلنت وما سببها
في السياقات المتعدده اعلنت عديد الولايات
في السودان حاله الطوارئ للتعاطي وللتماشي
وللتعامل بصوره فوريه وعادله مع كل ما
يطرا في ظل هذه التداعيات التي تعيشها مدن
السودان المختلفه بعد اشتباكات ومواجهات
مسلحه دخلت نحو الاسبوع الثالث هنا في
ولايه البحر الاحمر الشرق السودان تم
اعلان حاله الطوارئ يوم الامس ولمده 30
يوما هذه
القرارات المتعلقه بحاله الطوارئ كانت
قبلا قد استبقت بتكوين غرفه امنيه عرفت
بخليه الامن او الخليه الامنيه هنا في
ولايه البحر الاحمر هذه الخليه فيها وحدات
مختلفه بدءا من قياده المنطقه العسكريه
هنا في ولايه البحر الاحمر في مدينه
بورسودان بدءا بقياده الجيش قياده الشرطه
القوات الامنيه المختلفه الامن الاقتصادي
الاستخبارات العسكريه المخابرات العامه كل
هذه الوحدات الاداريه والوحدات العسكريه
والامنيه تعمل بصوره متناسقه مع بعضها
البعض حتى تخرج الولايه من اي ازمه قد
تحدث جراء ما يحدث في عدد من مدن السودان
وبعدها
مما يتخوفون هل يتخوفون من امور امنيه ام
يتخوفون من عدم القدره على التعامل مع
الكم الهائل الذي يصل الى بورت سودان
دائما في حاله الازمات ميسون تطرا بعض
التداعيات وهنالك ارتدادات لما يحدث من
اشتباكات ومواجهات قد تطرا ازمات اقتصاديه
ازمات مجتمعيه
بعض الامور قد تكون خارجه عن السيطره
تهريب بعض السلع بعض البضائع لا بد من ضبط
الامن الغذائي في المنطقه التي يعلم فيها
حاله الطوارئ المحروقات الوقود كل هذه
الاشياء عندما تصدر ولايه او مدينه او
اقليم حاله الطوارئ فان السلطات تحاول ان
تؤكد على قدرتها على التعامل على ضبط
الامور امور معاش الناس تامين الغذاء
تامين الوقود كل هذه الاشياء عندما يتم سن
حاله الطوارئ او اعلان حاله الطوارئ يكون
الامر بمثابه اعلان طوارئ التعامل يكون
بسرعه وبسرعه عاجله لا يتركون الامر
للتقاضي الذي قد يستمر ايام واشهر عليه
فان مثل هذه عندما تطلق عندما تتنزل الى
ارض الواقع فهذا يؤكد على ان الحكومه وان
السلطات تؤكد على دورها الرقابي تؤكد على
دورها الجوهري تؤكد على اهميه ان يكون
هنالك قرار سريع وعاجل للتعامل مع كل
المعطيات للتعامل مع كل الارتدادات
الاقتصاديه والسياسيه والامنيه التي قد
تطرا ونحن نتحدث وهنا في شرق السودان الاف
من رعايه الدول الاجنبيه ما زالوا حتى
الان في هذه المدينه عمليه تفويج مستمره
من الخرطوم الى شرق السودان عمليه مغادره
مستمره من مطار بورسودان من ميناء
بورسودان كل هذا الامر يستدعي قرارات
يستدعي يقظه يستدعي تعامل بصوره فوريه مع
كل هذه المعطيات الماثله هنا في المشهد في
شرق السودان نزار
ايضا بالنسبه
لبورتسودان هناك حاله من التعاضد والتكافل
اتجاه كل الناس التي تذهب الى بورتسودان
ان كان لتقيم فيها او لتكون ممرا حتى
تنتقل عبر ميناء بورتسودان او مطار
بورسودان الى الدول اخرى ومعظمها ذهب الى
السعوديه ماذا يمكن ان تخبرنا عن هذه
الحاله عن هذا التضامن والتكافل عن هذا
الاحساس الانساني بين الناس
ميسون الصور كثيره ومتعدده والقصص هنا
تروى بشكل يومي
لمواطنين لاسر فتحت بيوتها فتحت منازلها
اقتسمت اللقمه مع السوريين مع اليمنيين مع
الاجانب عدد من سائقي الاجره وسائقي
الركشات او ما تعرفون بالركشه في مدينه
بورسودان وفي السودان لا يتقاضون اي اجر
النظير نقلهم لاي اجنبي يصل الى هذه
المدينه في حال من التعاضد راينا كثيرا
امام نادي هيئه الموانئ البحريه وهذا
النادي على سبيل المثال هو ايضا فتح
ابوابه حتى يكون مركزا رئيسيا لحصر وتسجيل
رعايه دول الاجنبيه هنالك من يقوم بتوزيع
الماء راينا ايضا كبار السن يقومون بتوزيع
البلح على الصغار على الاطفال يوزعون
قوارير الماء هنالك اسر وصلت الى مراكز
التسجيل واطلقت نداءات لكل السوريين كل
اليمنيين على النساء ان يذهبن مباشره الى
البيوت ولا يفضلن ان يكونوا في الشارع كما
يظل الان الشباب والرجال وينتظرون دورهم
في توفيق اوضاعهم حتى يغادروا السودان
القصص كثيره صراحه ميسون جمعيات شبابيه
منفعله عدد من الدور الايوائيه الان ينشط
فيها الشباب الشابات مدينه بورسودان يقومن
بصنع الطعام يقمن باعداد الطعام لرعايه
دول الاجنبيه حتى ان رعايا الدول الاجنبيه
ومختلف الجنسيات عندما نستطلعهم ونتحدث
معهم عن اوضاعهم بعد ان يقدموا شكواهم
ويقدموا ما يعانون يؤكدون على مضمون واحد
باننا لابد لنا من ان نشكر الشعب السوداني
وهذه شهاده اعزاز وشكر لكل سودان في
الخرطوم في ام درمان في مدينه بورسودان
ايضا يرسلون رسائل بانهم بعد ان خرجوا من
الخرطوم وصولا الى هذه المدينه او الخرطوم
الى مصر او الى معابر مختلفه يقولون بان
السودانيين قدموا لهم الطعام قدموا
الافطار قدموا وجبه الغداء هذه السمات
يقولون بان الشعب السوداني لا يستحق كلما
حدث له وان السودانيين هم في لحمه واحده
ونحن نسعد جدا باننا كنا خلال السنوات
الماضيه في هذا الوطن الذي يتمتع فيه
السودانيون بهذا الاتفاقات النادره
ايضا على الاجواء في بورسودان وعلى كل هذه
القصص يعني لانه هو من اهم الامور الان هو
موضوع التكافل والتعاضد حتى يستطيع
السودان ان يقف من جديد
ويعود الى الاستقرار والى الامان اشكرك من
مدينه بورسودان وراس العربيه نزار
البلداوي
من الخرطوم تنضم اليه الان عروه الصادق
عادوا حزب الامه القوميه السيد السيد عروه
اهلا بك معنا بالنسبه
للمسار السياسي على الرغم من هذه الهدن
الاشتباكات ما زالت متقطعه انباء تتحدث عن
قبول الاطراف بالتفاوض وبارسال مفوضين
عنهم ولكن بنفس الوقت ايضا يبدا التصعيد
بانه لا نريد التفاوض نريد حسم المعركه
وخاصه مثلا من قبل الجيش كيف يمكن ان نصف
المشهد اليوم في السودان بعد ثلاثه اسابيع
تقريبا من هذا الاقتتال
اولا حياك الله السيده ميسون وحياه
مشاهدات ومشاهدين حدث وحيا طواقيمكم
العامله على راسهم نزار الببغداوي الهاشمي
في الخرطوم ونزاره البورسودان نامن الله
ان يحفظهم ويعزي عبركم والشعب السوداني في
فقده الجلل عزيزتي الموقف الان اليوم قد
يكون اهدا من الامس باعتبار ان الطلعات
الجويه خفت الاشتباكات الارضيه ايضا خاصه
بكثير وهنالك ايضا التطور في العمليه على
الارض
قبول الجنرالات ان ينتدب عنهما ممثلان
لجده باذن الله سيكون ذلك فيقولون الساعات
القادمه
هذا الموضوع استاذ عروه
باذن الله في غضون الساعات القادمه الان
الترتيبات في اتصال من الخارجيه السعوديه
لتوفير لوجستيات محدده متى ما تاكد ذلك
سيصل او سيفد الوفدان وفد الجيش ووفد
الدعم السريع الى جده لمناقشه امر الهدنه
الانسانيه وهي الاولويه التي ظللنا نطالب
بها منذ ان اندلعت هذه الحرب ويحمد لهما
ان استجابها ولو مؤخرا على ذات الصعيد
يسير التصعيد من داخل الخنادق وما هو
مفهوم من يكون التصعيد من داخل الخنادق
ومن خلف البنادق نبره الجنرالات
الميدانيين تكون عاليه فالسيد ياسر العطا
حديثه حديث جنرال يقود معركه في ام درمان
وكذلك السيد محمد حمدان يقول معركه في
الخرطوم ويمكن ان يقول دينارا الحروب ما
شاؤوا ولكن الحقيقه القطعيه التي قالت بها
حقائق التاريخ والواقع المعاش والغداء
المامول هي انه لا توجد حرب في السودان
استمرت وانتصرت الحرب بل انتصرت الى تفاوض
جلس فيه ط
لماذا الحرب ما دمنا سنذهب الى التفاوض
يعني ما دامت مدام الطرف لا يريد ان يحسم
لماذا يذهب الى هذه الحرب ويجعل
السودانيين يدفعون هذا الثمن الغالي يسال
عن ذلك الجنرالات ويتحملون وزر ذلك ولكننا
نحن كقوه سياسيه لا يوجد لدينا بندقيه
اقوى من بندقيهما ولكن لدينا الكلمه
والكلمه مسؤوليه ونفضل ان ندفن احياء وعلى
ان تدفن الكلمه في صدورنا لذلك نقول بها
وندفعهم دفعا نحو الجلوس الى الحوار
كما قال السيد ياسر عرمان الناطق الرسمي
باسم قوى الحريه والتغيير حيث دعا الى
مظاهرات تعم المناطق التي تشهد هدوءا هل
هذه المظاهرات برايك اذا نزلت الى الشوارع
من الممكن ان تكون عامل ضغط
الان الاولويه ليست للمظاهرات الان
المظاهرات منتظمه بطابع انساني اقولها لك
واقول لك ان السيدات نيالا وسيدات ولايه
النيل الازرق خرجنا في وقفات احتجاجيه ضد
الحرب هؤلاء امهات اكتوينا بنيران الحرب
هم الان يظاهرن يظاهرني اذا كنا في
المعسكرات النزوح او في المظاهرات التي
اندلعت في عواصم الدول المختلفه ضد الحرب
وفي امام السفارات الاحتياجات الولائيه
ستستمر وستتواصل ولكن الان المظاهرات تتخذ
طابع اخر وهو قطع الطرق امام النازحين
باستضافتهم في البيوت وايواء اسمه اطعامهم
وكسائهم ومعالجه وتطبيب جراحهم هذه هي
المظاهرات التي تعكس عليها وتعمل عليها
كثير من اللجان المقاومه كثير من اللجان
الاحياء وشكلت لذلك رف طوارئ في الولايات
من جهود ذاتيه في غياب كامل للسلطه
المركزية هل لديكم اي معلومات بانه هذين
الوفدين يعني سيت
واجبنا ان يلتزم الجنرالات باله ونمضي نحو
انتشار يسامحنا من الطرق ومن المشارح
ومواراتها واكراما المرضى واقاله عشرات
العافرين هذا هو هذه هي الاولويه الان
ايضا في ذلك ستتخاطب هذه القوه السياسيه
مع لنظرات باننا نريد ايضا اللحاق باهلنا
في الحدود الحدود المصريه والحدود الشعبيه
والحدود
الاثيوبيه التي وردت في تقاريركم هؤلاء
يعيشون اوضاع ماساويه واجب الدوله
المركزيه للعاقبهم وواجبنا نحن كقوه
سياسيه ايضا ان نقدم ما نستطيعه وفي ذلك
تشكلنا غرف طوارئ للحاق بهم في اعلى
الصعيد الاقليمي والمحلي والدولي في
مهاجرنا المختلفه نشطه حزب الامه القومي
مثلا في تفعيل 40 مكتب اجتمعت بالامس بيت
تطلع بهذا الدور على ذات على هذا النسق
نسير او لويتنا انسانيه سنتقدم في الملف
الانساني سنسير الى نحو المعادله السياسيه
لننجي بلادنا من الانزلاق الحرب الاهليه
والتمزق والتدخل الخارجي
حزب الامه القومي كنت معي من الخرطوم
ادى القتال في السودان الى نزوح عشرات
الالاف من الاشخاص عبر النياله عاصمه
جنوبيه دارفور مع تزايد المخاوف بشان
احتمال حدوث ازمه انسانيه كارثيه مع مئات
الالاف من اللاجئين
[موسيقى]
ما تسالوا عمليات النحب والسرقه تطالب
المنشات الرسميه والحكوميه السودانيه بسبب
الاقتتال الدائر والانفلات الامنيه الحاصل
في البلاد الصحفي صالح ابو علامه رصد
العربيه بعضا من مشاهد النهب التي طالت
وزاره التربيه والتوجيه في جنوب دارفور
هذه هي وزاره التربيه والتوجيه بجنوبه
دارفور تم الاعتداء عليها تماما وتم تدمير
كل المكاتب والاقسام الخاصه بالامتحانات
والخاصه بعمل التربيه والتوجيه هنا في
جنوب دارفور جنوب دارفور فيها تتم طباعه
جميع الامتحانات لاقليم دارفور تم تدمير
كامل لجميع ماكينات الطباعه في هذه
الوزاره كما تم نهب جميع الاجسام داخل هذه
الوزاره دمائر كبير للبنيه التحتيه
والتربويه والتعليميه في جنوب دارفور
يحتاج العمل لاعاده هذا المكان الى وقت
تحويل الخسائر لا حصر لها حتى الان تواصل
اللجان عملها لحصر الخسائر المتعلقه
بعمليات السلب والنهب داخل الوزارات
المختلفه ايضا تم نهب وزاره الماليه
بالولايه ومراكز تتبع للصحه مثل الصحه
الايجابيه ومركز التحصين ووزاره الصحه
وغيرها من المرافق الحكوميه الهامه في
جنوب دارفور
قالت مسؤوله الاتصالات الاقليميه في
برنامج الغذاء العالمي لشرق افريقيا ان
الطرفي الصراعى في السودان بحاجه الى
الاجتماع معا لايجاد حل للنزاع حيث ان
الاشتباكات المستمره قد تؤثر سلبيا على
جميع انحاء المنطقه
بالنسبه لبرنامج الاغذيه العالمي فان اهم
من الاكبر في الوقت الحالي هو اذا لم
يتوقف الصراع في السودان قريبا فسيكون
التاثير السلبي في جميع انحاء المنطقه
كبيره نحن نرى فعليا ما لا يقل عن عشرين
الف لاجئ عبروا الحدود الى تشاد زملائنا
يقولون ايضا ان العدد مشابه في جنوب
السودان ان لم يكن اكثر يعبروا الى جنوب
السودان نحن نفكر في اللاجئين الموجودين
في السودان وكيف يمكنهم العوده الى
بلدانهم الاصليه غير المستقره اصلا كما
ينبغي ان تكون عند عودتهم لذا فان التاثير
المضاعف للمنطقه كبيره انه مصدر قلق حقيقي
ونحتاج فقط الى ايجاد السلام فنحن بحاجه
الى ان يجتمع الطرفات صراعي معا ويجدوا
طريقه لحل الن لان ذلك قد يؤدي الى زعزعه
استقرار المنطقه باكملها
وهذا عاش الجامعه العربيه تقول قد نصل
لوقف اطلاق النار في السودان خلال اسبوع
او اسبوعين اذا حسب الجامعه العربيه تقول
بانه قد يصل الى وقف اطلاق نار في السودان
خلال اسبوع او اسبوعين الان ننتقل الى ما
قاله الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي بان
تدفق العديد من السودانيين الى مصر سيخلق
صعوبات في البلاد السيسي اشار الى ان
بلاده ستتاثر بشكل واضح بالنزاع في
السودان في حاله تدفق المزيد من اللاجئين
خاصه ان مصر تعاني من صعوبات اقتصاديه في
ظل الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا كما اضاف
ان مصر في الاصل استقبلت حوالي تسعه
ملايين لاجئ من السودان وليبيا وسوريا
واليمن ودول اخرى
وفي متابعه لتطورات الاوضاع الصحيه قال
المتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه في ولايه
الخرطوم محمد ابراهيم عبد الرحمن ان 39
مستشفى خرجت عن الخدمه منذ بدء الاشتباكات
مؤكدا العربيه ان قوات الدعم السريع حولت
بعض المستشفيات لسكنات عسكريه عبد الرحمن
دعا الى فتحي وممرات انسانيه لاغاثه
الضحايا
المستشفيات التي توقفت على الخدمه منذ
صباح يوم 15 وحتى اليوم هي 39 مستشفى هذه
المستشفيات هي في مناطق الاشتباكات حتى
تاريخ اليوم مناطق غير امنه هي المستشفيات
التي متاخمه لمناطق الاشتباك شارع القصر
وشارع
المطار
والقياده والاذاعه ومركز
ومركز البحري
تفاصيل اكثر عن الوضع الصحي في الخرطوم
ينضم الينا دكتور عطيه عبد الله عطيه
سكرتير نقابه اطباء السودان دكتور عطيه
اهلا بكم معنا الوضع في المستشفيات وايضا
الصيدليات ماذا عن الطاقم الطبيه
والمستلزمات الطبيه
شكرا جزيلا لكم السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
تعالى وبركاته في بدا خالص التعازل
لجماهير الشعب السوداني الصحه والعافيه
لكل الجرحى والمصابين عوده الحميده لكل
المفقودين نعم نحن الان
نواجه طرفي الصراع ونحاول ان يعني
المجتمع الدولي على وقف
هذه الحرب العباسيه وايضا نتحدث مع
المنظمات الدوليه في السودان
لاستجلاب الدعم انساني
وايضا تحريك ما لديها من مخازنها في نفس
التوقيت للمستشفيات ونعمل على تشغيل
المستشفيات الطرفيه ولكن الان نحن ايضا
اصبح هنالك عبء جديد وهو تصحيح هذه
المعلومات المضلله التي تحاول ان تخلق
عالم خيالي موازي الذين يتحدثون هذه
المستشفيات
هذه المعلومات التي ذكرتيها والتي ذكرتها
وزاره الخرطوم معلومات مغلوطه تماما وهذه
المعلومات غير عاريه تماما من الصحه
دكتور عطيه افدنا المعلومات الصحيحه نحن
لدينا اكثر من 69 او 59 مستشفى وخرج من
الخدمه لدينا 16 مستشفى تم استهدافهم
عسكريا وخ خارج الخدمه لدينا 19 مستشفى
هي
تم اخلاء المرضى فيها لاسباب الامنيه
المذكوره لدينا 13 شهيد من الكوادر الطبيه
حتى الان لدينا مستشفيات فقط
في الخرطوم حول الخرطوم تعمل عندما نقول
مستشفى نعني بكلمه مستشفى لا يمكن تصنيف
مركز صحي او مركز رعايه صحيه اوليه على
انه مستشفى
فقط تعمل في الخرطوم ومحيطها في كل كل
السودان بما فيها الخرطوم بكل السودان
كل السودان بما فيها الخرطوم وايضا هذه
حتى المستشفيات 26 التي نذكرها بعضا منها
لا يستطيع ان يقوى ان يقول انه هو مستشفى
هل لديكم مستلزمات طبيه هل لديكم ادويه
وهذه المخازن التي تحدثت عنها الان بانكم
تطالبون المنظمات الدوليه بان ترسلها لكم
هل هي موجوده في هذه المخازن لانه يقال
بانه كان هناك عمليات نهب وسرقه هل هي
متواجده متوفره
للامانه والتاريخ تم تحريك عدد من
المعينات
الطبيه من المخازن القريبه عدد من
المنظمات ابلت بلاء حسنا وهم مشكورين
انابه عن الشعب السوداني لوقوفهم في هذا
الوقت التوقيت الحساس بالتاكيد عدد من
المنظمات هي حاولت جاهزه في تحريك عدد من
من مخازنها تم الشراء من الاسواق وايضا
نشكر هنا عدد من الشركات الوطنيه التي
يعني خاطرت بحياتها وفتحت مخازنها وتم
الشراء منها وتشغيل عدد من المستشفيات
الطرفيه نحن الان نتحدث عن مستشار الطرفيه
يتم تشغيلها حتى تتمكن من من مقابله هذا
العدد الهائل من المرضى نحن الان ليس
مشكلتنا فقط ضحايا العمليات العسكريه ولكن
ايضا هنالك مرضى من
من كبار الصين واصحاب الامراض المزمنه
وايضا الذين يحتاجون للمتابعه الطبيه
الدوريه الان هنالك عدد من المنظمات
التواصل مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بانه
هناك مناشدات موضوع
مستشفى الكلى والادويه للكلى هل بانها غير
متوفره بايجاز لو سمحت
بايجاز كل مخزون غسيل الكلى في كل السودان
بما فيه الخرطوم تتوقف في ظرف اسبوع او
اسبوعين اذا لم يعني يتم هنالك امداد
عندما نقول اسبوع او اسبوعين اسبوع او
اسبوعين هي بناء على عدد مستشفيات هنالك
ولايات دكتور عطيه عبد الله عطيه نعود
لمتابعه طبعا هذا الموضوع في ساعاتنا
القادمه
نقابه اطباء السودان شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
طبعا كل المراكز العطله بحاجه الحرب بين
الان نحن برامج ظروفك الحاصل
[موسيقى]
في هذه الظروف على صعبه وعدم امكانيات
اللي ما موجوده هنا
بعض الادويه والمعدات
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات